yeah i mean there's so much i want to
ask you because it's so fascinating for
me um
maybe you can help me find this
documentary i was i went down the rabbit
hole on youtube 10 years ago and it was
the man who spoke 100 language
and he worked uh he he visited the white
house during the eisenhower and he was
like well liked and everybody liked them
and then i couldn't find this
documentary anywhere so i'm like is this
a figment of my imagination or there's
these stories valiant thor in the um
yeah the stranger at the pentagon yeah
yeah where a dude shows up that's super
smart says he's from venus and he's
hanging out in the pentagon of these
things and he's giving us all this
knowledge um
two things
three things one it's either true or
it's not two
he's lying he's not from venus or
something
or three um you know he's maybe he's
from here or you know in and he's lying
from where he's from
um but the idea
of i'll say it this way i personally in
my own opinion subscribe
to
face-to-face interactions and technology
transfer and all that kind of stuff i
believe there's a possibility for that
to have existed
i say this because i have pieces of
wreckage
from the 40s under a defense contract
with the government right now and you
can look that up if you look up tom
delong army material you'll see all the
articles it's the first
it's the first time in history the us
government's talking about doing
you know a defense contract on purported
ufo material we've had that for a couple
years being studied in like crazy ways i
can't talk much about it but
if i have that i would imagine that some
of the governments on the world have a
lot more than i got you know and they're
not we're not saying that this is real
we're saying it's highly
um
it's it's highly anomalous it's the
engineering on this one piece looks to
be [ __ ] crazy and and that is still
still looking to be the the case here
after having this contract for the past
couple years they've been studying it so
there's nothing to this we would have
lost that contract like two months into
it you know so we'll see where it goes
and all that kind of stuff but if if i
have a piece and it's looking to be
pretty gnarly then i'm assuming that
other places have some way bigger pieces
so
if that's the case then
then then it's easy for me to say well
then i feel
there's a high likelihood that there's
been encounters there's been
conversations there's been interactions
there's been landings there's been
technology transfers there's been
something um but i i do not know like i
can sit there and say yeah they brought
me in and i hung out with this dude that
said he's from venus you know that's
never going to happen but um i just
think it's highly likely that something
like that exists
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude